PRIYANKA VERGARDIA:
Hey, it's Priyanka.
So far, we've looked at
how Critter Junction was
able to launch a new
app on Google Cloud.
Today, let's take
a look at how they
can enable their apps
to gracefully handle
peaks and dips in traffic.
[THEME MUSIC]
Critter Junction is becoming
very popular with more users
than ever.
The game is all about playing
daily, collecting items
and furniture to
decorate your house,
and interacting
with other players.
As we saw in the
previous episode,
they have a range
of compute options
to deploy their
workloads, but they
chose to migrate some game
service to Compute Engine.
As their traffic grew,
they were struggling
to provision
additional instances
globally for anytime of the day.
This led to overutilized Compute
and created constant pressure
on their operations teams.
Clearly, they need
an automated way
to handle their growing users
and maintain performance
to keep their users
coming back daily.
So let's see what Critter
Junction should do.
They should use a
global load balancer
and managed instance groups
to scale and distribute
the traffic automatically.
This keeps the
operations team happy
and the user satisfied
with great performance.
Managed instance groups provide
features such as autoscaling,
autohealing, auto updating,
and regional multiple zone
deployments.
To understand this
better, let's step back
and understand how a Compute
Engine Instance is created.
You create a custom image for
your application, which is then
used to create an instance,
and to make this reusable,
you create an instance template.
In an instance template,
you can not only
set up configuration
of the VM, but also
run startup scripts to pull down
the latest version of your code
when the machine starts up.
You can also attach disk
templates with all the software
dependencies your app requires.
Or you leave it
as an empty shell
that gets populated
by a CICD pipeline.
These templates then
automate the creation
of Compute Engine
instances at scale
through managed instance groups.
Let's see how this works with
a simple web app example.
Let's head over to our project
in the Google Cloud Console
and create a firewall
rule under VPC networks
to allow HTTP traffic to the
app we're about to deploy.
Provide a name,
default-allow-http,
default network, targets,
select the specific target tags,
and set the target
tag as http-server.
Set the source filter to IP
ranges and provide 0.0.0.0/0
to allow access for
all IP addresses.
For ports and protocol,
select TCP and enter 80.
And then Create.
Now, head over to
the Compute Engine
and create an instance template.
Give it a name, select machine
type, set boot disk image to
[INAUDIBLE],, and check
Allow HTTP Traffic.
Under the Management
tab, find automation
and add to startup script.
This script causes each
instance to run a simple web
application during startup,
and finally, Create.
Link to the tutorial is
included below for you
to refer to the sample script.
Now that we have an
instance template,
we can create an instance
group using this template.
Create an instance group.
Give it a name.
Select multiple
zones under location.
This protects us
from zonal failures.
Select a region, and
under Instance Template,
select a template
we just created.
Now, set autoscaling
mode to Autoscale,
autoscaling policy
to CPU utilization.
You can also set policy to HTTP
load balancing or monitoring
metrics.
We're going to talk
more about HTTP load
balancing in a minute.
We will set the target CPU
usage to 60%, minimum number
of instances to 3.
It is recommended that you
provision enough instances so
that if an entire
zone was to go down,
the remaining
instances still meet
the minimum number required.
And set the max number
of instances to 6
to make sure you don't
incur additional cost.
We will set the cool down
period to 120 seconds.
Make this number is
higher than the time
it takes for CPU utilization of
the VM to initially stabilize.
We will skip setting a
health check for now,
but we'll cover that
in the next episode.
After that, just Create.
Wait for a few minutes until all
of the instances are running,
then go to VM
instances, and click
on the external
IP of the instance
to see the demo web page.
Now that we have it
all set up, let's
generate traffic so we can
see the autoscaling in action.
Open Cloud Shell.
Create a local bash project
using export project ID
command.
Run this bash script.
Again, that's included
in the link below.
This script
increases load, which
leads to increase in CPU
utilization for our demo app.
When it reaches the
target value of 60%,
the autoscaling
starts increasing
the size of our instance.
Now, let's navigate
to our Monitoring tab
in our instance
group, and we can
see the increasing
number of instances
as the CPU usage is increasing.
And you can see the
scaled down effect
by running a similar
bash script that
decreases the load, leading to
a decrease in CPU utilization.
And after a few minutes
of stabilization period,
the autoscaler prompts to
decrease the instance group
size, which is visible in
the monitoring tab as well.
Critter Junction
has global users.
They want the users
from Singapore
to end up on Asia East web
server while the ones in the US
end up on US Central Region.
For this, they would use
global load balancing,
which routes traffic to
the nearest web server
instance, which helps
reduce latency and improve
performance.
From there, the
internal load balancer
distributes the traffic to
manage and maintain load
across the back ends.
These instance groups
in different regions
autoscale using an
HTTP load balancing
policy to scale seamlessly,
regardless of where
the traffic is coming from.
Not only was Critter
Junction able to automate
the scaling of their
compute instances
using autoscaling and
managed instance groups,
they were also able to improve
performance by serving traffic
from instances closest to their
users using the global load
balancing.
But there's one
more step to scale,
identifying the instances
that are unhealthy
and replacing them
automatically.
So stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we will cover how Critter
Junction can setup autohealing
and keep their users happy.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]